what's the best Coney in uh in Detroit
huh it says absorbers or uh
L George's absorbers on the east side on
Six Mile and Gunston
um and yeah George is on the west side
on like Greenfield and Six Mile hmm
what makes a like a good Coney place is
it like does the hot dog have to be fire
or does it like they got oh there's so
much stuff on the menu right I only get
Coney dogs sometimes it's really like
anywhere in Detroit is to cook because
the people be cooking the same thing and
it taste different like you feel me like
it's just really to cook because
sometimes I go to Coney and get some
pancakes or french toast and it could be
the middle of the night but sometimes I
go get corned beef and some chili cheese
fries or winged the chili cheese fries
it's always the cook because somebody
might burn your wingdings or you drink
like wing dings yeah what's that it's
like small chickens it's small chicken
wings it's like a baby like a baby
chicken like baby chicken wings like
that dings that's wild like they cut the
little flat part off the wings like the
and it's just the thing
the wing gangs hey wing dings I just
know that we what was the name of that
burger place you brought us Burgers from
or the [ __ ] Patties or this fat one
uh
it was you got them big babies it was
the juiciest most gigantic
[ __ ] hamburger for sure food exchange
they come the big baby come with corned
beef and a burger on oh my God it was
just a lot going on uh-huh it was gas
though it was amazing it was amazing
great I like the food out there no I I
really only like food at home for real I
was eating at the uh you know where they
got terrible food it's at the MGM in
Detroit all the food court choices there
are terrible oh that's the casino though
I'm aware it was like but I was just
like there's nothing you gotta go to the
neighborhoods like oh I was there or the
strip clubs like went to the strip club
too
I did not go to um
trust is that it truth truth didn't go
there I heard that was good where'd you
go to Pantheon
no we went to uh Ace of Spades with
Mozzy and then uh
Street Lord one sent it to some white
club uh that was terrible Coliseum maybe
oh my God it was like a bunch of Juggalo
women were dancing
okay you wanted to see the black girls I
just I don't [ __ ] with white women bro
but you know what it was was like it was
like our first night in town and like he
couldn't come out with us Heather's sick
and so I I felt like he wanted to send
us somewhere he thought we'd be safe so
he sent us there and then we walked in
and I was like he wanted to see the big
booty black girls with the bbls the
Spades was was great I'm hit great
talent yeah
I didn't go no it was Lil Blade's
birthday party in there and um Ozzy was
performing
payroll Giovanni was there it was a good
time I love Detroit man it was very
chill I liked it it was [ __ ] and
that'd be it ain't like everybody make
it seem like it's really fun [ __ ]
loved it I was like I tell everybody I'm
like yo Detroit's fire everybody was
super nice I also had zero clue that you
guys are like you could throw a rock and
hit Canada
do you go to Canada sometimes no
just why not it's like you could just
drive over there I'm back I just got my
passport and I just stopped being a
felon but I ain't stopped being a
failure I just got off felony probation
so I like how you said that I just
stopped being a felon by the way
congratulations I'm glad you made that
life choice but uh do you have because
it's hard to get into Canada if you have
a felony right yeah but could you get
are you fine though I'm trying to get
cool with Drake
I mean I'm sure that'll happen right he
hasn't latched on to a Detroit artist
yet he'll latch on to somebody cousin
here Detroit artist he just took a
picture with Drake
um
and a little baby took the picture I'm
like that's fire I am surprised that
Drake hasn't um
really dug in with like a Detroit artist
yet it feels like the type of thing he
would do you know he brought um cash
doll out one time I mean
how long ago was that like 2017 or 18 19
maybe probably something like that you
probably remember it yeah he could show
by her out Castro's a legend Dej loves a
legend shout out to Dave